you spent a lot of you time on camera
playing teens in skins of course and
that is coming back as net for serious
southern tell us what you're looking
forward to about returning to what
something I guess you maybe thought you
wouldn't have a return to yeah I never
ever thought I would return to at all
and I didn't really want to until I
found out that they really wanted to
focus this mini film on that kind of age
you go through where you're not a
teenager anymore but you're not quite an
adult and you don't you're trying to
work out what it means to become an
adult and I was totally going through
that in real life so it felt important
for me to go back to skins because it
had been such an important part of my
life and a part of me growing up to then
experience that again with them and tell
that story because I couldn't really
think of any other mainstream program
that had done that I think a lot of
people want to focus on University and
then you're sort of late 20s and stuff
but that really kind of early time where
you kind of lost you know completely
overwhelmed and you move to a new city
and all these things and then I wanted
to go back and work with Lily loveless
again I really wanted to work with
child's Martin the director again so for
me I really I can't wait to better under
the way is going from that teen hood to
adulthood is it and you kind of done
that in a way on camera yourself haven't
you see what are you taking from your
own life experience back into skins now
I think we all take something its such
an important time and it's totally like
yeah I do know the story line that if he
goes down is completely different to
what I've gone down obviously but I
think it's still there the friendships
you know things that you thought were
majorly important when you were 14 and
suddenly aren't any more and kind of
want to focus on work and different
things so I kind of took that expected
so what can we look forward to with the
new series of skins oh there's a lot
there's a lot going on and she was
starts working the city and makes her
way up and she's living with my only so
it's all about the balance of their
friendship
you